What's your question, buddy? Okay. Well,
um, so, uh, I don't mean to turn the
tables or anything, but this question is
kind of personal. Oh, I don't mind
sharing. Who paid you to come and attack
me and my personal life, Derek?
No, nobody. Um, well, I don't mind
sharing the story with the chat, though.
So, it's up to you. It's Look, if you
feel uncomfortable, you don't need to
share, but go ahead. What is it? Okay.
So, let me just tell you. All right. So,
my aunt um she All right. So, she
committed suic you know she died from
Yeah. But um she left the note before
she died and then um she wrote on the
note God please forgive me for you know
and like she was very depressed and my
dad told me that like she couldn't
handle herself. She was very depressed.
And I spoke to many Christians and they
say, "Oh, it's unforgivable. She's
damned to hell forever." No. Here's here
here's the problem, the situation you're
putting me in. I know there are certain
traditions that would say if you commit
that cuts you off from Christ and his
grace, you're in hell. So now I'm going
to just answer from scripture. Are you
ready?
Just from scripture. Now you're going to
have to wrestle with any tradition that
you belong to that may say otherwise.
And I'm not here to pitch you against
your tradition. So you may be a
Catholic. They may teach one thing.
Church of the East may teach one thing.
I'm not an expert on these traditions.
But I can tell you from scripture, from
scripture, there
isn't any sin that's unforgivable except
the blasphemy of the Holy Spirit. The
only sin that Jesus said will not be
forgiven, the blaspheming of the Holy
Spirit. and
committing is never classified as one of
those acts by which you blasphe the Holy
Spirit and therefore remain condemned in
your sin. Go to Mark 3:28-30.
Okay. Oh, my Bible's upside down. Okay.
See, now notice what you did. So, you
just gave it You're in a dark room with
great light and you have an upside down
Bible. You know what that's you know
people from the dark side like to have
things in reverse like upside down
crosses. What are you trying to do here?
Uh Mark 3 28-30
verily I say to you all sins shall be
forgiven unto the sons of men and
blasphemies wherewithsoever they shall
blaspheme. But he that shall blasphem
against the Holy Ghost has never or or
has no forgiveness, but is in but is in
danger of eternal damnation
because they gohead. No, go finish it.
Yeah. 30. Uh because they said he has an
unclean spirit. Okay. Did you pay
attention? No, that's the 30, brother. I
don't you want to give me 31, but did
you pay attention? All sins and
blaspheings are forgiven except the
blasphemy against the Holy Spirit.
Right. Yeah. Now go to Matthew 12:31-32.
[Music]
Well, if you're a believer in Jesus and
you die, you will be happier. So the
rabbi who doesn't believe in Jesus can't
answer that question because he has no
biblical basis to answer the question.
But if you're a believer in Jesus and
you die, will you be happier?
Absolutely. There is nothing better to
be in the visible physical presence of
Jesus Christ. And that's why Paul said
to be depart to be with Christ is far
better. To depart to be with Christ is
far better. Right? Anyway, that's
Philippians 1:21-23. But anyway, read
for me Matthew 12:31-32.
Where uh wherefore I say unto you, all
manner of sin and blasphemy shall be
forgiven unto men, but the blasphemy
against the Holy Ghost shall not be
forgiven unto men. And whosoever speaks
a word against the son of man, it shall
be forgiven. But whosoever speaks
against the Holy Ghost, it shall not be
forgiven him, neither in this world,
neither in the world to come. No one can
add a second unforgivable sin. Nobody.
No one. No one. Jesus who God in the
flesh says, "All sins, all manners of
blasphemies will be forgiven even when
you blasphe me. But the only sin that
will never be forgiven is the blasphemy
of the Holy Spirit. So if anyone tells
you is unforgivable, say, "Show me from
scripture where is a means, a way of
blaspheing the Holy Spirit." Because the
only sin Jesus said won't be forgiven is
blaspheing the Holy Spirit. So that's
where I rest. Okay. Um Yeah. Uh I And
like their response would be like, "Oh,
like oh, like they don't have time to
repent or like they can't repent." See,
again, they're being stupid. Where does
Jesus say the sinfulness of unrepentance
won't be forgiven? So, not repenting, is
that a sin?
Um,
if you don't repent, it's not a sin or
no, let me ask. Hey, do you know? Oh,
yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, did Jesus say all
sins will be forgiven
except the blessing of the Holy Spirit?
Yeah. So where do you get that if you
fail to confess and repent of all your
sins, you won't be forgiven when Jesus
says all sins will be forgiven except
the blessing of the Holy Spirit. And
secondly, are they sure they want to
argue that way? Do they have a clear
conscience that when they die, every sin
that they've committed, they've repented
of? So there aren't sins that you've
forgotten that you've laid buried within
your own life that you're unaware or
forgot of that you haven't repented of.
So that means now they argue themselves
they're going to hell too.
Yes. True.
Right. So then you challenge them. Say,
"Wait, so you're saying I must repent of
every sin to be forgiven? So that means
none of us are going to go to heaven,
right? What do you mean? Can you
guarantee any of you will be able to
recall, let alone repent of every sin
you've committed? Because according to
you, if I don't repent of a sin, then I
will die condemned."
Yeah, that's true. That doesn't work. So
challenge and say, "Prove to me is a way
of blaspheing the Holy Spirit." Then
I'll agree with you it's unforgivable.
If you can't, don't go beyond what is
written. And I'm just giving you a
scriptural answer. And there may be
traditions that will say is
unforgivable. Or they may say that
that's in the hands of God. So we won't
pray over their body and bury them,
let's say, in a Christian cemetery. But
it doesn't mean they're not forgiven. It
means as far as we're concerned, we
cannot pray over that person and bury
that person in a Christian cemetery, but
his fate in the hands of God.
Yeah. Right. Yeah. Right. Yeah. So, I'm
just going by scripture. So if you have
a tradition because there are people
that go to certain churches that their
tradition may be that it's not
forgivable or they may take the more
balanced approach saying look someone
who commits we can't pray over that body
and we can't bury him in Christian
cemetery that doesn't mean he's not
forgiven that means now he's in the
hands of God and the judge of all the
earth shall do what is just Genesis
18:25
okay so that's that's my answer brother
that's the best I can do Okay. Uh, can I
add on to that? You want to add to it?
Go ahead, man. So, okay. So, my dad also
told me my grandmother, she had a dream
and I I don't want to like, you know,
make you interpret it. That's not, you
know, like and but like she said that
she had a dream and that she saw like
she had a dream of like her miscarriaged
baby and then like and like my aunt in
heaven. There you go. And then there you
go. Now there's a lot of out of body
experiences, near-death experiences
where it's medically proven. People see
things that you cannot explain away. And
you'll find in many of the testimonies,
let's say a mother miscarried and then
that child that died in the womb, either
she sees that child or someone else sees
that child and unbeknownst to that
child, let's say, hey, you know, I saw
my sister, you know, and she told me
that you miscarried and but she's with
Jesus. Something that is beyond just
coincidence. So that happens a lot. But
again, someone will say you don't you
don't base your faith on dreams. And
absolutely true. If a dream or vision
contradicts the Bible, then either it's
your overactive imagination or a satanic
deception. But if there's a dream and
vision that doesn't contradict the Bible
and doesn't encourage you to do
something contrary to scripture, then
you know what? I have no problem that
this dream was of God. But if someone
thinks unforgivable, they'll say, "No,
that was a satanic deception or her
overactive imagination." So that's not
going to convince anyone that doesn't
want to be convinced.
Okay.
All right. Right. Yeah. That's only
that's the best I can tell you, brother.
That's all I can. And I know people are
there going to be people are going to
disagree with me. That's fine. At the
end of the day, even if they disagree
with me, that doesn't mean I'm right,
they're wrong, or they're right, they're
wrong. At the end of the day, it's up to
God. It's an ends of God. I can only
give you an answer from what's revealed.
And in scripture, I don't see any
indication that automatically lands you
in hell because Jesus said there's only
one sin that won't be forgiven, the
blasting Holy Spirit. And Jesus cannot
lie. So unless you can convince me is a
way of blasphing the Holy Spirit, then
you're going to have to put that under
the sin that can be forgiven.
Yeah. Yeah, cuz don't forget people
committed suic in the Bible. Saul
committed. He fell on his sword and
himself. So Jesus surely knew about and
if that was unforgivable, he could have
said there are two sins that won't be
forgiven. Lasting the Holy Spirit
and Right. Yeah. Right. All right. Hope
that answered him, man. Well, how about
like Judas? Wasn't he full of the devil
though? And like So was your aunt of the
devil or was Judas of the devil? Judas.
Okay. So, how are you going to compare
your aunt to Judas when she left you a
note saying she begs the Lord Jesus to
forgive her, but she can't continue in
misery? Does that sound like Judas?
Yeah. Yeah. No. Okay. No. Right. Don't
confuse Judas with your aunt. And not
only that, how many sons of the devil
are martyed for their cause? So, does
that mean because they're martyed that
means that they are truly of God,
they're going to heaven? So you see I'm
using the reverse because you're saying,
"Well, Judas himself and he went to
hell." Yeah. Because Judas was of the
devil. Even if he didn't kill himself,
someone else killed him, he'd still end
up in hell, right? Yeah. You get my
point? Yeah, I get it. Yeah. So, hope
that's clear, brother.